et ben oui ça y est on est là on regarde
ça comment est ce que vous allez
aujourd'hui est-ce que ça roule oui oui
vous voir à travers la lentille ça a
l'air d'aller on va se parler de quoi
jean louis mermaz parle de saint vaast
parler d'un nouvel microsoft surface pro
8 l'aca a écrit si noir sur blanc blanc
sur noir un petit gris mais c'est très
joli nouvelle microsoft surface produite
alors venez déjà présenté la surface
crochète c'était un petit moment déjà
c'était super intéressant alors c'est
pas forcément les produits qui sont
faits pour tout le monde les surfaces
autant je les aime bien autant je les
trouve intéressantes autant il faut
qu'elle vienne correspondre à votre adn
on est sur un produit nomade on est sur
un produit un petit peu deux en un petit
peu 3 en 1 d'autant plus que cette
surface pro 8 n'est pas vendu
directement avec son clavier et encore
moins avec son style et c'est un petit
peu dommage parce que c'est vraiment
tout l'adn de lui alors je vais j'ai
fait il ya produit se fait beaucoup de
produits je vais vous montrer je vais
vous le dire je veux expliquer parce que
c'est quand même dommage d'avoir une
surface comme ça une très jolie surface
qu'on peut utiliser en mode cheval est
bien évidemment comme ça pour le poser
sur une table et de ne pas avoir sa
cover sa colère qui s'avère à dire de
protection pour votre écran ça c'est
déjà quand même relativement banal puis
surtout ça vous fait un vrai clavier et
en plus c'est un tout qui est vachement
bien et qui vient de la surface pro x
que je vous avais présenté il ya un
petit moment aussi et bien c'est le fait
d'avoir ça la regarde et ça c'est le
petit stylet de microsoft qui est super
intéressant il ya plein de choses qui
sont nouvelles avec ce style et il va y
avoir des vibrations à petit qu'il va y
avoir un petit rangement qui est
extrêmement bien cachés qui écoule bref
ça nous fait un très joli produit signé
microsoft avec des nouveautés bien
évidemment avec une très jolie mise à
jour on va donc regarder ce produit on
va donc voir ce qu'il est fait pour vous
parce que c'est vraiment la question à
se poser c'est est-ce que la microsoft
surface pro 8 est fait pour vous oui ou
alors pas du tout
soyons clair microsoft s'est vraiment
bien bossé son hardware c'est avec
microsoft on le connaît depuis le début
avec du software de dingue si on en plus
un ordinateur qui est natif sous windows
onze familles dont là c'est quand même
plutôt pas mal mais on va commencer par
s'enlever ça pour se concentrer sur la
partie est bien écran c'est vraiment
l'ordinateur puisque tout est ici c'est
tout l'intérêt des surfaces on restera
un produit qui est très fin extrêmement
fins très bien design et il ya pas
beaucoup de boutons n'est sur
l'essentiel le bouton pour venir
l'allumé pour l'éteindre on a de l'autre
côté du bouton pour le volume et
regarder les connectiques ça c'est aussi
super intéressant on va avoir une petite
prise jack 3.5 ici pour venir écouter de
la musique très facilement si on le
souhaite au keynote de ce côté là à
voyez il n'y a rien d'autre on va
ensuite de l'autre côté on va avoir deux
ports usb c'est thunderball 4 qui vous
permettront de venir brancher deux
moniteurs si vous le souhaitez pourquoi
pas de dire brancher un disque dur
externe si vous êtes créatif ve vous
avez besoin de stockage pourquoi pas et
tous les accessoires qui peuvent venir
se connecter directement en usb c'est
thunderball 4 et en plus c'est une
nouveauté qui est vraiment intéressant
ça c'est la première fois que ça arrive
ici est bien c'est que vos prises usb
c'est vous serviront à venir charger ici
votre surface produite donc assez banal
et puis sinon qu on a rechargé vous avez
le port surface connect parce que oui on
connaît l'histoire c'est un port
propriétaire signé microsoft que vous
avez comme ça alors c'est vrai qu'il ya
un côté un peu vieillot avec se porte
sur trois connecteurs c'est vrai que ça
marche il ya rien à dire il vient se
positionner comme ça facilement il se
recharge vous l'enlevez ils cherchent
plus enfin bref c'est extrêmement simple
mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui la
connectique on va venir retrouver
majoritairement que ce soit pour un
ordinateur qui soit pour une tablette
c'est en usb c'est donc c'est aussi
intéressant de pouvoir retrouver de
l'usbc ici d'autant plus que vous avez
peut-être des accessoires directement
existant en usb c'est donc c'est le
premier point voyez au niveau de la
connectique après une fouille a rien de
bien dame de saoula vous avez deux
petits ports qui vous serviront à venir
connecter votre clavier très simplement
c'est aimante et ils viennent se
retrouver au plat presque bon faut bien
les mettre en face voyez ici reconnaître
pour ferney et c'est pratique mais ça
c'est encore une autre histoire
empreinte tout à l'heure donc voyez
c'est plutôt simple c'est efficace et
autre point qui est vraiment extrêmement
important ici eh bien ces petits pieds
multi positions vous pouvez bien le
poser comme ça ce qui fait que vous
l'avez en face de vous et c'est
extrêmement pratique pour venir à bosser
si vous voulez l'incliner davantage et
bien vous pouvez vous le descendent et
quasiment 180 degrés je dis bien
quasiment parce que voyez il ya quand
même un petit angle ce qui vous permet
de l'avoir un peu en face de vous
permettre de venir taper directement si
vous voulez un petit clavier virtuel et
que vous voulez pas acheter le clavier
en plus clavier et depuis que vous
pouvez acheter sur le stand microsoft
sont toutes les bonnes crémeries
d'ailleurs si ces produits vous
intéresse vous mais un lien en bas dans
la description et si vous connaissez le
savoir faire et la qualité hardware de
microsoft est bien voulu que cette
charnière elle est super top ça il faut
vraiment venir là la manipuler pour se
rend compte très très très belle
finition on est sur un boîtier en alu
anodisé signature on retrouve le logo de
microsoft sites web cam à l'arrière
rageux vous l'avons tout de suite une
petite webcam qui est planqué juste là
là c'est une 10 mégapixels qui vous
permet de monter jusqu'en quatre cas au
niveau de la résolution pour la vidéo
c'est plutôt pas mal de mecs qui
arrivent en faisant une petite haut de
gamme de 5 mégapixels est ici uniquement
pour hamza filmer en 1080p alors le truc
qui est un petit peu ballot ici c'est
qu'il ne mette la meilleure caméra
derrière alors c'est vrai je peux
comprendre mais on n'est pas ici sur un
smartphone donc on va pas la prendre et
on va pas les faire des photos et on va
pas les films et les gens comme ça je
préférerais avoir la meilleure qualité
devant en visio pour pouvoir moi me
filmer lorsque je viens travailler
lorsque je viens appelé ma famille
d'autant plus avec le co vide on voit
qu'on a besoin de systèmes pour se
filmer et pour venir communiquer avec
l'extérieur tout ça serait bien mieux de
mettre la meilleure caméra devant plutôt
que derrière ça c'est un peu un peu
dommage avec cet écran est quand même
plutôt pas mal à regarder un pelage le
met face à moi ils à nous reconnaître
avec windows et l'eau un petit message
sympa ça que j'aime bien moins gardé son
mignon chez microsoft nous sommes
heureux de vous revoir monsieur grubb
bienvenue bienvenue à toi au plat on y
va on déverrouille ces pratiques marche
pas si vous avez vu ma vidéo sur windows
11 je vous présente toutes les
nouveautés je vous explique un petit peu
et bien ça c'est vachement intéressant
ça me plaît en fait j'aime beaucoup
c'est l'idée d'avoir un nouvel os une
mise à jour par rapport à windows 10 ne
se disent pro ça c'est une certitude
aller voir ma vidéo vous saurez tout sur
les nouveautés de windows rose quasiment
tout cas des fonctionnalités à part lié
à microsoft surface ici mais ce que
j'aime bien et si effectivement c'est ça
change un peu donc ici l'expérience est
intéressante avec windows onze familles
et si vous êtes un gamer vous pouvez
jouer dans le club c'est ce que je veux
dire vous recommander ici parce que même
si la machine est bien c'est pas un
ordinateur qui est destiné pour le
gaming donc vous allez pouvoir faire
tourner quelques jeux ok mais sans y
aller trop fort ce que je vous conseille
c'est de venir jouer dans le club vous
pouvez avoir un mois offert de xbox game
passe et si ça vous plaît pouvait
prendre un abonnement comme ça vous
pourrez jouer sur vos device n'importe
lequel ces pratiques c'est bien c'est
dans le club et sa part me retaper dans
les parlements de votre machine parce
que votre machine elle est sympa mais en
terme de performance on n'a pas non plus
une agrif forcément on est plutôt sur un
ordinaire or qui va être destinés à de
la productivité plus plus plus on va
tourner sur un intel core i5 ou i7 2 11e
génération alors si vous voulez les
références et je les ai là le x5 ses 1
1135 g7 et le i7 c1 1185 g7 comme ça
vous savez tous que vous avez soit 8
soit 16 soit 32 gigas de ram c'est de la
lainière 4x si vous avez des ssd 128 256
les deux sont amovibles vous voulez par
là pour les enlever les changer sinon
vous avez du 512 et du 1 giga côté
graphique on est sûr de lindt l iris 10
m'envoyer c'est une carte qui est
intégré d'ailleurs c'est intéressant
parce que grâce à votre nouveau port
thunderbolt 4 et bien pouvait venir
ajouter une carte graphique externe
alors si vous voulez plus de performance
je suis pas parfait que cette surface
pro elles servent pour du gaming alors
vous pouvez rajouter une carte graphique
il va être plus intéressant souhaité
faire tourner un photoshop à la peu plus
loin avec nous des calques quelques
programmes qui vont être un peu gourmand
pour un peu de 3d mais une fois de plus
pour gaming c'est pas trop ça ne
m'étonne qu'il vous faudra parlons
l'écran parce que l'écran il est
justement très intéressant il ya une
nouveauté qui arrivait cette année ben
oui c'est passé de la nouveauté vient
d'arriver c'est un écran avec un taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 hertz qui va
apporter plus de fluidité alors pourrait
se dire ok cool pour le gaming une fois
de plus pour moi la surface trop vite
elle n'est pas dédié gaming mais ça vous
apportera plus de confort et plus de
fluidité au niveau des animations à ce
que vous allez dire scrollé donc ça
c'est plutôt bien l'écran saint
pixelsense bien évidemment les sur un
ratio 3/2 cdu 2880 par 1920 pixels à 267
qui fait par pouce au fait pourquoi pas
complètement tactile ça vous l'avez vu
c'est plutôt normal avec une prise en
charge de la division ok on a ce qu'il
faut ici on a deux haut-parleurs de 2
watts avec du dolby et mossoul et 10
pouvez vous connecter avec une petite
prise jack et vous avez du bluetooth 5.1
pour vos écouteurs sans fil si vous le
souhaitez regarder jouer un peu de son
ope la pousse à fond
ça marche pas mal
le niveau du volume va rester correct
après on est quand même temps du médium
c'est pas expérience la plus dingue
qu'on va retrouver aujourd'hui pour moi
le champion toute catégorie au niveau de
l'expérience sonore sur un ordinateur
c'est vraiment au niveau des macbook pro
ici c'est plutôt pas mal ça reste
efficace mais si on va avoir la
meilleure expérience faut brancher un
casque clairement ça c'est bien donc on
a quelque chose qui fonctionne bien pour
le multimédia alors on va le dire pour
autant est ce que je vais dire acheter
une surface pro 8 pour du multimédia je
suis pas convaincu pour ma cette surface
produite elle va être vraiment
intéressant dans plusieurs cas d'usagé à
savoir d'ailleurs c'est des usages qui
corresponde vous à vos besoins
productivité certitude vous avez un bel
écran 13 pouces ça marche bien donc il
ya un côté tablette il ya le fait
d'avoir de la modularité le fait de
pouvoir l'emmener facilement avec soin
le fait de venir poser comme ça
directement avec son petit pied jusqu'à
180 degrés quasiment 180 degrés ça c'est
vachement bien donc modularité
productivité familiale peut venir faire
de la visio contre direz-vous comme un
peu tous les ordinateurs aujourd'hui
mais surtout l'adn de cette bécane c'est
de l'emmener partout avec soi mais je
dirais que ce qui va vraiment apporter
en expérience et bien c'est d'avoir le
clavier le clavier qui a un nom
d'ailleurs il s'appelle le clavier
signatures pour surface pro alors ce que
la grèce n'échappe en surface pro je
trouve très intéressante pourquoi parce
qu'il vient augmenter l'expérience mais
il vient aussi augmenter le coût il
n'est pas vendu avec ça c'est un petit
peu dommage c'est même carrément dommage
donc il vient se poser très pratique
vous ouvrez derrière posés çà comme çà
élus à regarder il monte il vient se
poser là ça vous permet déjà d'avoir un
petit angle là voyez pour vos poignets
donc là il ya un côté déjà moins
fatiguant est ce que vous allez lire
travailler taper comme ça si c'est ça la
course de touche je trouve très très
bonne il ya un très bon confort au
niveau de ce clavier le truc que j'ai à
dire un petit peu reproché à ce clavier
c'est que lorsque vous appuyez comme ça
on est à côté un peu rebond voyez on se
balade directement dessus je trouve que
le trackpad est aussi assez confort
alors c'est vrai que j'aurais bien aimé
la voir un poil plus grands ce trackpad
peut-être un peu plus grands là est un
petit peu plus grand malheur après je
sais pas si c'est une contrainte
technique
c'est vrai que je peux pas vous dire
comme ça ça convient pas ça ira très
bien mais c'est vrai que j'aime bien
d'avoir un peu plus grand je me suis
habitué avec les mêmes nous prenons des
traits pas un poil plus grand et là
c'est vrai que c'est bon c'est un petit
point de détail mais il reste malgré
tout très confortable point qui est
aussi très très bien avec ce clavier
c'est qu'il est complètement rétro
éclairé donc là ya de la lumière dans le
passé vous en rendre compte ça se passe
directement par la touche confort ok
mais surtout tout l'intérêt se situe ici
lorsque vous l'ouvrez bah oui qu'on peut
toujours utiliser à plat si vous le
souhaitez comme ça gardez ça fonctionne
hop on peut venir taper très facilement
il est à plat c'est bien mais surtout
vous voulez sortir le petit thil et
c'est le surface slim peine 2 le nom est
un petit peu râlant je me le style est
très cool ce stylet vous permet quoi
vous permet de venir dessiner prendre
des notes griffonnées je passe si vous
aimez griffonné mais moi j'y vois
vraiment un usage extrêmement fort ici
la prise de notes on s'en fiche un peu
c'est un usage en plus mais c'est plus
du dessin donc vous pouvez utiliser
votre surface pro comme une petite
tablette graphique car et non comme une
tablette graphique avec les applications
dédiées vous venez dessinée vous venez
naviguer vous venez faire ce que vous
voulez avec moi c'est plutôt cool et en
plus de ça il ya un truc qui est
vachement sympa on va venir se mettre
quoi alors je ne suis pas dans même un
graphiste mais je trouve quand même
vachement sympa alors j'aime bien l'idée
de la forme comme ça parce qu'en termes
de prise en main c'est vraiment vraiment
vraiment pas mal on vient le vide s'est
très facilement entre ses doigts vous
avez le petit bouton ici là qui vous
servira pour dire inchangé doute il a
par exemple c'est une petite gueule je
vais venir reprendre à mes dessins
l'envoyer je suis vraiment pas le
champion du dessin je trouve vraiment
bien en termes de prise en main de la
même manière on peut venir à travailler
ici est dessinée s'amuser comme on le
souhaite hop la petite capture d'écran
avec le bouton derrière bref c'est un
bon outil dans la mesure vous en avez
besoin je n'utilise pas de style et je
ne grille phone pas je ne dessine pas je
suis très mauvais dans ce domaine là
mais si vous êtes graphiste et que vous
voulez un stylet et bien expérience
sociale est quand même vachement bien
réussi et surtout est ce qui est
vraiment intéressant vous posez là c'est
de la charge sans fil vous voyez là ils
s'allument il se met en charge comme ça
vous vous posez pas de questions vous
savez en permanence où il est vous ne
risquez pas de le perdre donc ça c'est
un côté malin qu'on avait déjà avec la
surface pro x ne connaît pas avec la
surface pro7 ya notre parc important ici
c'est toute la partie autonomie alors
microsoft nous allons jusqu'à 16 heures
d'autonomie en utilisation normale
autant vous dire que ça va quand même
loin qu'est ce que l'utilisation normale
c'est la question à venir se poser vous
avez cinq minutes la réalité c'est que
vous allez pouvoir regarder entre presse
14 heures ça dépend ce que vous faites
ça dépend de l'usagé que vous en avez si
vous regardez des films en 1080p pendant
des heures vous aurez pas de souci mais
si vous avez bonne utilisation mixte
avec des programmes qui vont être un
petit peu gourmand par moment forcément
ça va descendre un peu plus bas parcours
est ce qui est très pratique et ses
hommes vous l'avez juste là vous avez un
blog de charge de 65 watts qui est
fourni avec alors ça je vous le dis une
fois de plus utiliser le port surface
connect mais vous pouvez très bien
utiliser un autre chargeur de ce que
j'ai trouvé merci beaucoup chéri mais
vous pouvez très bien utiliser n'importe
quel chargeur à 65 watts dans le
commerce bonne qualité une fois de plus
sans problème en usb c'est si vous ne
voulez pas vous embêter avec le port
microsoft surface connecte tout en
sachant que c'est bien un petit peu le
problème vous allez me reprendre un port
usb c'est qu'ils ne soient pas
disponibles pour un moniteur pour un
disque dur etc pendant le temps vous
allez les charges et ça il faut tenir
compte aussi bon pourquoi pas conserver
ces petits objets qui seront fournies
avec d'autant plus que si vous avez une
batterie de 51,5 water et ça il faut le
savoir alors laissez-moi vous est ce que
ça coûte et bah ouais c'est tout noté
lycée sur ma feuille ça vous le savez
alors en fait ce qui est super
intéressant savoir et si c'est qu'on est
sur une offre à tiroirs vous pouvez
commencer du i 5 gigas de ram 128 go de
stockage jusqu'aux îles 7 32 gigas de
ram 1 tera de stockage et ça forcément
ça n'a pas coûté le même prix alors je
vous dis tout de suite si vous commencez
sur un i5 lui giga de ram 128 vous êtes
à 1179 euros mais c'est uniquement la
bécane du vous n'aurai absolument pas de
clavier vous n'aurez pas de stylet avec
le clavier seule écoute 179,99 et le
stylet seul 129 euros 99 ça peut faire
rire et puis vous avez un package à 279
euros 99 vous avez l'ensemble c'est bien
c'est pratique pour moi cette bécane là
il faut forcément l'acheter avec le
clavier je vois pas l'intérêt venir
acheter ça alors je peux y a que ça
marche parce que c'est pas une belles
bécanes qui fonctionnera pas avec
séparer c'est une très belle machine on
peut l'utiliser sans mais tout l'intérêt
de cet ordinateur là que cette surface
produite c'est d'avoir le clavier c'est
d'avoir le stylet c'est d'abord le
package qui fonctionnera bien et à
réfléchir en plus si vous avez besoin
d'une petite souris sans fil qu'on peut
venir aussi acheté en supplément
d'envoyer cette configuration elle est
extrêmement importante mais ce que je
vous conseille pas c'est de prendre 8
gigas de ram nissan- 28 juillet de
stockage pourquoi parce que c'est trop
petit il faut penser à vos usages de
demain alors c'est un petit peu
compliqué comme ça mais je vous le redis
à chaque fois lorsque vous venez acheter
un ordinateur pour moi le minimum ça va
être 16 giga de ram et 512 giga de
stockage 256 ça c'est un petit peu petit
aussi par moments il se peut que vous
ayez besoin d'un petit peu plus voilà
confie que je retiens ça va être saisi
un drame un intel core i7 et vos cinq
sens 12 giga de stockage à
1979 euros ça tombe bien c'est aussi là
dès ma naissance il faut rajouter le
package clavier style et ça augmente
tout de suite le prix mais c'est là où
ça devient extrêmement intéressante si
vous voulez un peu moins de stockage il
va falloir penser à stockées dans le
cloud pourquoi pas avec one drive ça
peut être une solution mais une fois de
plus ça vous rend voir vous et à vos
usages quel usage vous auriez d'une
surface produite dès que le mois a
marqué le morbihan commentaires si vous
reconnaissez cette vidéo si vous êtes
probablement recherche d'une surface
profiter vous posez des questions dessus
est ce que ça pourrait être intéressant
pauvre qu'est ce que vous allez en faire
trop l'utilité très clairement on peut
venir dessiner on peut venir griffonné
un peu venir faire des croquis
extrêmement facilement c'est une machine
qui est très polyvalente le gaming dans
le claude surtout sort il faut rajouter
une carte graphique sur vallet un petit
peu plus loin mais il faut de plus pour
moi c'est pas l'idée de cette bécane là
les montages vidéo s'est pas non plus
vraiment l'idée on peut le faire vous
montez la ram vous y arriverez avec un
i7 vous en ferai mais bon c'est pas
vraiment son adn on est plus sur une
très jolie bécane sur de la mobilité on
va penser un ordinateur qu'on va emmener
partout facilement avec soi je vais
penser à des commerciaux qui vont
glisser très facilement dans un sac je
pense à des personnes qui sont nomades
qui prennent la route qui vont voir des
clients sap est extrêmement intéressante
c'est une très très très très très très
très jolie des canes très belle finition
signé microsoft mais elle fera pas fait
pour tout le monde d'ailleurs dit moi
est ce qu'elle sera fait pour vous oui
non pas comment vous le remarquez bien
évidemment on bat en commentaire moi je
la trouve bien je trouve intéressante ce
qui m'intéresse réellement c'est les
évolutions qu'on va voir on va voir la
onzième génération de processeurs intel
ici un écran quand on a fauché ce nom de
sang vers ce qui va améliorer le confort
en visionnage le fait d'avoir tous ses
porcs en usb sait plus du tout où aucun
port en usb à ce sont les les nouveautés
les plus importantes et les plus
intéressantes c'est dans microsoft une
fois de plus travailler bien donc si
vous avez des jeunes surface générations
ultérieures et bien ça peut être
intéressant de venir changer ici si vous
n'en avez pas posez vous la question des
usagers est ce que cette machine est
fait pour vous oui ou non sur ce je vous
embrasse donne rendez vous très
rapidement il va continuer à parler de
teck les bisous à bientôt ciao
[Musique]